-It's fun that we get to hang out all day together,
and it's kind of awesome.
-This is my third appearance in this episode...
[ Laughter ]
-...of your show. -That's a record. Yeah.
-Wow! -You broke a record there.
Hey, I want to say. You always look good, obviously.
-Oh, thank you. -I appreciate this.
You're modeling your new clothes.
-You noticed? -Yes, I did.
-This is my new Lands' End collection.
-I'm known for fashion,
and so I did this partnership with Lands' End.
-You really did. This is -- Look at this.
This is you modeling, by the way.
Do you like modeling? -Oh, look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's you --
-You think Gigi's back there taking notes right now?
[ Laughter ] -I don't.
I don't think so at all, by the way. No.
Ooh. Look at this one. Look at this stranger.
-Ah, look at that. [ Audience awws ]
-Yeah. Hey. Man of mystery right there.
-Wait a minute. I can't tell if that's an "aww" or a...
I can't tell what kind of an "aww" that is.
-It's a sexy "aww." Oh, it was?
-Yeah. People are into that. Yeah. Right? Yeah.
-Did you just say, "Some people are into that"?
What did you just say? -Some people are into that.
-Okay. -Yeah.
-I kind like your hand -- No matter where it is,
your hands kind of go in the same kind of area.
[ Laughter ] It's kind of interesting.
Your eyes kind of focus to one thing, you know?
-What the hell's wrong with you?
[ Laughter ]
Your eyes go to one thing.
-You've got Lands' End. You've got Lands' End.
-Your eyes are what goes to one thing.
-You tell me, man. This is how Blake Shelton models.
It's like...
"How you doing, man?
I'm doing good.
Pretty good."
[ Applause ]
This is a big deal. I'm happy that you're here.
I want to talk -- This is football night right now.
-It is. -It's a big deal for NBC.
You're an Arizona Cardinals --
-Don't tell me what happened in the game
because I've been here doing all this stuff with you all.
-Yeah, I won't tell you. It's a good game, though.
It was fantastic. But none of your teams --
You're Arizona Cardinals, right?
-Arizona Cardinals fan, yes. Die-hard.
-Yeah, but how?
How -- How -- How? -What do you mean?
They're my team.
They're gonna win the Super Bowl this year.
We are going to win the Super Bowl this year.
-Oh, I thought you're saying you're going to the Super Bowl.
That, I could see happening. You could go to the Super Bowl.
-I'm not here to promote Arizona Cardinals.
Come on, man. Sell my music.
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know what I'm saying?
-Back -- -Thank you.
-I do like the song, by the way. "No Body."
"No Body."
-Yeah, not "nobody."
"No Body," like it's two different words.
Like, the word is in two words. Yeah.
-Yeah, the word is in two words. "No Body."
-People probably weren't watching earlier
when we did the game.
-They did, but when you do this --
"No Body." You're like, "I don't want no body but yours," right?
-Yeah, "no body." -Mm-hmm.
-Like, you know the stance that you were doing,
that my hands are always -- Like, no body.
-You're doing it. No body.
-Anybody else is that...
-So this is a song about no -- There's no body.
-Right. No -- -It's about a murder.
The body wasn't found. -I guess it could be.
-It's like a "Dateline" type of a podcast song.
"No body was found."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's fantastic.
They don't write songs like that anymore.
-Hey, you're not talking about my mullet, either.
You haven't made fun of that yet, either.
You've made fun of the actual music.
But now I need you to make fun of the actual...
-I'll make fun of the actual mullet,
but I'll make fun of the actual mullet from actual you in 2005.
That is your real...
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is your real --
-Questlove.
-Wow. Oh, my gosh. -The Roots...
-Why -- Why did you go back to the mullet for this?
I saw the video, by the way, which is awesome.
I do love it.
-This is actually one of our talking points,
so I know what to say here. -Yeah, go for it.
[ Laughter ]
-So, when we recorded -- when we recorded --
-You are the worst guest we've ever had on
"The Tonight Show" in the history of any guest.
I have had people come on and not talk,
and they were better guests than you are.
[ Laughter ]
-When we recorded the song,
I thought that it sounded like '90s country music.
So, that's back when you used to listen to country music,
back in the '90s. -I listen to country now.
-It reminds me of the songs
that we used to hear back then on the radio.
-Like "Boot Scootin' Boogie." -Exactly.
That was the '90s.
-♪ Boot scootin' boogie ♪
♪ Here we go, do-si-do ♪
[ Mumbling ] ♪ Come on, boogie ♪
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
♪ And Cadillac, blackjack ♪
♪ Na, na, na, oh, boogie ♪
That's a good song.
"No Body" is a different song.
-Do you mess up the lyrics...
Do you mess up the lyrics so you don't have to pay
for, like, a copyright fee?
Or is it because you genuinely don't remember?
-[To tune of "Desperado"] ♪ No body ♪
Why don't you come to your senses?
♪ You've been out ridin' fences ♪
No, but it is kind of a good '90s
kind of line-dance feel to "No Body."
-Back to the talking points.
That's why when we made the video,
I wanted to do,
like, a line-dancing type thing in the video.
Is it on there?
-It doesn't say line dancing. -It's number eight.
-Number eight. Yeah. Line dancing.
-We wanted to do -- -Can you do any for us?
Can you do any line dancing for us now?
-That's not in the talking points.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sure. -It's not in there.
-Well, can you? -What -- No.
I can't do that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I'll do it. I'll do it.
-Like a freestyle. Ready?
♪♪
Oh, double.
You didn't see it coming twice. Did you?
Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I like that.
It's a good, fun song, and it goes with the tour.
Your tour is "Back to the Honky Tonk."
-I'm so much better of a guest than Justin Timberlake.
[ Laughter ]
Ratings go through the roof.
-Justin, hit mute. Justin, hit mute.
-Take that, Justin.
-You're starting February 16th in Lincoln, Nebraska,
the "Back to the Honky Tonk" tour.
-Yeah. -That's so you.
Do you remember when we hung out once?
We were at a concert of yours.
I came out and sang a song with you.
And then I didn't leave.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't leave, and then I go, "I'll sing another one."
You're like, "I think you should just --
Jimmy Fallon, everybody." And I go --
I started singing another one. Maybe we sang four songs.
-I'd love for you to do that.
We're playing in Buffalo, so maybe you should swing on by.
That's -- That's here in New York.
-I can do -- -It would be great
if you came on by.
Maybe we could do "Bring the Ice"
and then some of our other favorites.
-We have a bunch of favorite songs.
You have Sioux Falls. You have St. Paul.
Minnesota, Greensboro. Knoxville, Tennessee.
That's my jam. Tennessee. -Yep.
What other songs do you like?
"No Body." -Hey.
-Do y'all have a new album you need to promote or anything?
-This is -- This is -- Let me tell you something.
-Y'all wanna take this seat?
-Every time you come on,
you perform for us, you're great with us.
And I just want to say thank you for coming on
and doing also the Zoom shows, as well.
-You're welcome.
We have run out of talking points now.
Haven't we? You're welcome. I was happy to do it.
-I didn't even get into -- What are you gonna talk about?
Line dancing? -No, no, I was going to say.
That's when I got the haircut, when we were doing Zoom.
Gwen cut my hair. Remember? You were there.
-Yeah. They put my initials in your hair.
-That's right. -I do. I remember that.
-But let's talk about "The Voice."
That's something everyone can agree on.
"The Voice." You have Gwen Stefani as a coach.
-Yes. -And now, finally,
it's husband and wife. -Yes, that's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is Gwen competitive? -She isn't. Uh...
-What? What are you laughing at? -She's not that competitive.
If she were sitting here right now,
she would tell you she's not that competitive.
But she loves to see these people that she works with
on her team... -Win.
-...to do well and win hopefully, you know?
She did win the show once --
I think the last season she was on.
-And Camila Cabello, as well, is a new judge.
-Cami-- Yeah.
Have you met Camila? -Of course.
-She's got a lot to say, that girl.
I mean, she talks a lot.
Kelly's not on this season, but...
-Makes up for it? -She makes up for it.
Camila has a lot to say. -A lot to say. Yeah, yeah.
I could be a judge on "the voice,
and say if this song is good or bad.
Be like, "Hey, that's terrible. You should quit the business."
[ Laughter ] -Wow. You would say that?
Would you be that rough on people?
-Of course, I would. I tell it like it is.
You know, when people see me, they go,
"Jimmy Fallon doesn't mess around.
He cuts to the, uh, you know."
-Chase! -The chase. Thank you.
-Cuts to the chase.
-You see? Teamwork. I work with people, too.
-I can see that. -Team building.
I work with people. We're all on the same team here.
You're very like, "I'm going to win.
I'm getting a standing ovation. I'm Blake Shelton."
I'm a man of the people
and I go, "We all win if we all work together."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's you and "no body" else.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a look at the season premiere
of Blake Shelton's "The Voice" on Blake Shelton's NBC
and Blake Shelton's Peacock. Take a look.
-You should have seen the conversations
happening back here while you were singing.
It was like, "Oh, she's real good."
-It was me spearheading this
being like, "She's really good. Why aren't you turning?"
-And then by the time we got to the end,
it was like, "What are we doing?!
Let's -- What are we doing?"
-[ Muffled speaking ]
-Oh! How did he do that? Mine doesn't do that.
-Why do you get all the cool things?
-Can y'all hear her? -And nobody ever...
-Barely. -Is her mic on?
-You can't hear her? I know because my mute button
really does work, doesn't it?
-Why does yours do that?! -It's part of my contract.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, buddy. That's how you do it.
Standing ovation. -Thank you.
-One of my favorite guests. -Thank you.
-Blake -- Look at this. A standing ovation.
They want you. -For me?
-They want you to leave. [ Laughs ]
Blake Shelton.
"The Voice" premieres September 19th.
He's on tour. Check him out.
Gigi Hadid joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.